the prophet saw mentioned that the
bridge between belief and disbelief is
abandoning salah if you're struggling
with your salah right now well we got
the perfect solution for you and that
solution is the adan app this cell phone
we usually have it and is using us
instead of us using it but with the
adana you can use it in perfect
alignment with your life the adan app is
already used by 40 million believers
around the world why because it caters
to your islamic lifestyle on top of this
a lot of times you get the
welcome back to the release podcast
in the dunya we're joined here
with look at this handsome guy man
and this guy as well i'm about to grow
all right all right for real what are we
talking about today bro uh we're getting
into something very important very
important okay
guys
muslim men
the biggest thing that we deal with is
our nafs
right whether you're married whether
you're not married
it's very difficult and this is why it's
you know
said for us to lower our gaze now it's
also for women as well like women should
lower their gaze but let's be honest
as men like we are visual
you know we speak we've spoken about
this many times
and as men you know we see something and
we're just captivated by it so
when it's involved with our sexual
desires at the same times like it
becomes
even harder and this is why like we're
bringing it into today's video because
it's something that has to be talked
about we have to discuss a game plan
here for the brothers
because there are brothers that are
married that are
going through this brothers that are not
married
primarily i'd say the brothers that are
not married they're the ones that are
really really going through this
um and they resort to things which
are not permissible
they resort to
[Music]
let's uh for the purpose of the
algorithm we will use self love getting
to describe
the m word so self love
and we will say p for the videos about
that
you're gonna forget that in like five
minutes bro they they resort to getting
off
and this is not this is not good i mean
come on like
yeah even if if you guys weren't muslim
would you think that's all right no
there's something about it that
just doesn't say right with your feather
bro yeah the guilt
what what are you doing bro
she's talking about oh stuck for life
y'all could see what i was seeing but
going bro i don't think we have a
soundbite for that one man
how dare you
okay so
like i said we want to lay out a game
plan here
the game plan first off
you got to figure out why it is that
you're dealing with what you're dealing
with
so we'll get into that all right from
y'all's perspective why do you think men
are dealing with this issue aside from
the fact that we're just visual
creatures there's so many i think one of
the things is just it's a form of
escapism you're escaping from something
i ask most of my clients right usually
it comes down to either they're escaping
from the reality that they need to
change something to get the intimacy
back popping with the wife or
they are
miserable with their job or there's some
there's some stress or something that
they're running away from which is
causing them to resort to this
that's very true
i'm going to talk about this from mainly
a non-married person perspective because
usually people most of the time bring
the problem into marriage not develop a
problem in marriage unless they're just
not intimate with their wife and it's
almost as if they're single so
i would say that the main issue that
young men have is basically seeing women
everywhere no matter where you go
if you have tick-tock instagram twitter
youtube any social media
that has ever existed
you're going to see young beautiful
women and when you see that you're gonna
whether it's for a second or you're
staring at it you're going to feel
something it's unfortunate but it's
everywhere you go outside you see it in
the magazines it's there the tv is there
at the malls everywhere except like
dimension the house of allah
alhamdulillah just don't turn around you
know don't look at the sister section
inshallah you'll be good um
so that's a lot to do with lowering gays
you know it's difficult to lower your
gaze when you're scrolling through your
phone you scroll down and directly in
your line of sight is something that
tick tock wants you to see but you know
damn well you shouldn't be looking at it
and that is going to trigger these
emotions that you want to do blah blah
blah you don't have an outlet and then
you start one thing leads to another
that's the very simplistic answer there
are more steps i'll talk about later on
that like habits and atmosphere and all
that stuff that leads you to the point
where you're actually doing it which are
very very important to talk about but
for now i'll leave my answer at that
that's the main perpetrator these
emotions that you're talking about that
rise within us as men right yeah we
talked about mental health last week and
it's not it's not the worst thing in the
world to have these emotions a matter of
fact it makes us human and in islam we
don't shun these emotions we don't have
a taboo on sexuality or having urges and
desires we have permissible outlets and
we have impermissible outlets that's
what you're trying to say right yeah
yeah and that's not bad that we have
these yeah in the main issue the main
issue is is feeding into this by looking
at things you shouldn't be looking at
whether it's purposeful or not that's
why the pros and cons told us or sorry
allah commanded us in the quran
so you come from the perspective of a
dude who's not made yes
no you fired you are married
and
[Music]
you coming from a merry place like
what do you think
married men like why do you think they
go to this place where
they start struggling with it i think i
have three
potential answers that i want to give
you number one they came into the
marriage with this issue
number two they're away from their wives
and number three they're with their
wives but something ain't happening bro
they ain't getting none
and
i want to focus on
mainly the last one at the end obviously
because it's something i think is is
really you know we can work with that
there's it's fixable you know
but the first two are a little more
complex usually
when you and and there's dangers of it
too which we'll talk about inshallah i
don't know if you talked about this in
the briefing but we do want to talk
about you know ed and stuff that could
happen if you do it too much you know
but main story is or long story short if
you have a
contingency with
getting off to self-love
and you've been doing this for a few
years and you finally get married
self-love
self-love i think it ain't even
self-love listen we'll use the self-love
as for the algorithm right because we
can't we can't say
getting off too much bro
you don't know what's going to be
censored today subhan allah
okay continue
but for the purpose of this self-love
um if you are loving yourself
too much before marriage once you do get
married and this is a phenomenon with a
lot of women too right because we don't
want to rule out the sisters here this
is something that's affecting both
subhanallah
um
[Music]
no spouse will be able to please you the
way you please yourself
and this is something that is gonna take
people a little bit of time to
understand especially the single
brothers and sisters but
intimacy with a spouse is way different
than if you're doing haram with yourself
it's extremely different
and
that's the reason why a lot of people
form stuff like erectile dysfunction
because no partner will be able to
please you the way you have conditioned
yourself to be pleased
right and this affects women more
psychologically
but it does affect men more
by numbers because i see more men
addicted to watching than women
so this is the first thing um the second
thing was when you are with your wife
but you're not with her so for example
um i know a couple people i'm not gonna
mention any names here right no name
zone but a couple of uh brothers we have
they have multiple wives mashallah
and when they're with one wife
they have a halal intimacy obviously
everything is good mashallah
and they travel to another country and
they have another wife there
not for the sole purpose of obviously
intimacy but they have multiple wives
multiple spouses and it's a permissible
outlet it's it's something that is
permissible in islam and they're
fulfilling each other's rights and
everything's good however
some people don't have multiple lives or
they're alone in a time where let's say
they're addicted to intimacy or they're
getting too used to intimacy so let's
say you're with your spouse and you
actually don't have control over your
enough so like on how saying but because
you're with your wife 24 7 you can just
get it 24 7.
so to speak so you actually never got to
a point where you're controlling enough
you're just always with your wife so
it's always permissible anyway
now you take this individual and you
take him into an environment where he
has no women yeah and just his phone
you can already put two and two together
what's going to happen because he never
got over the discipline or over the urge
and and addiction and never form that
discipline to kind of like okay i'm okay
having access to intimacy but i'll say
no sometimes you know so when he finally
gets no access he doesn't know what to
do and then the last thing we can always
talk about later about you know a man or
a woman who
is in a relationship or marriage and
intimacy is not happening inshallah
that's what the future episodes are for
that's why i want to go into it uh but
yeah bro rami what about you
i mean what's the question
what's your question bro he always spoke
oh i'm the legend yeah he said the point
from a
like someone who's not married you said
point from someone who is married
and i guess i would just add on just so
this part of the the game playing here
is that another reason why people
tend to have this issue is because of
something that happened in their
childhood
like if y'all didn't watch the video
that we made on mental health make sure
to
watch this video first and then head
over and watch that one
uh you know inshallah
but usually we have things that happen
in our childhood if we do not take care
of these things
then it ends up following us into
adulthood and if it follows us into
adulthood
we have no ideas there
it's going to be controlling us from
behind the scenes and
like maybe someone was abused as a kid
and because they were abused as a kid
you know like it was this outlet for
them like you said it's a distraction
it's a distraction and then on top of
that
like romney said it's
constantly there they're being bombarded
with it everywhere they go they're being
exposed to it so
not only is it normal for them it's been
normalized
but it's also something that they are
pulled to because it it distracts them
if
it makes them forget the fact that they
went through so-and-so thing you know
and like i said in the
video with the mental health
you know when we have this issue we have
some kind of issue
whatever we did
back then it worked for us then
but it it doesn't work for us anymore so
a lot of guys a lot of brothers out here
you know
this i'm not here to condemn you i'm i'm
not the one that's
here to pass judgment
um
[Music]
what what was done in the past was done
in the past you know like at some point
or another like it
i guess it helped you through but now
it's time like you got to really
put things into perspective and and
really
see okay
in which of these
does your specific situation lie
you know like was it what rami said
was it what fire said was it what i said
was it a combination
you know figuring that out you have to
figure out why are you struggling with
this issue you have to figure out
exactly the details for yourself in
order for you to
fully develop this game plan alright so
the next part of this game plan now you
know
why you are experiencing what you are
experiencing
so now you got to look at
what does your life look like
your routine
you know routine is a big big big part
here like have you ever tried to
um start something new in your life like
maybe like a hobby or some kind of habit
or something waking up early or
something it's always the hardest in the
beginning yeah but like not only is it
the hardest in the beginning but have
you noticed like
if you keep everything else in your life
the same but then try to change this one
thing
it kind of doesn't stick but then when
you try to like change
a few extra things give me an example an
example
so let's say you're trying to
make this
habit of working out more
okay let's say
usually in your day what you do is
you're working sitting down working
um then when you're done working
you go and you sit down on the couch and
now you're watching tv for the rest of
the night so you sedentary all day long
so you're basically going to add now
working out to the equation
so let's say you're going to work out
like two or three times a week
right so you get off work and then you
go work out but then what do you do when
you get off
or
you do when you get off
what do you do when you get out the gym
you go
back home you eat and you sit your ass
back down on the couch
right
so you have this pattern of behavior
that it's like you going to the gym two
or three times a week is not going to
break
your cyclical
pattern of behavior your cycle
right now if you were to let's say go to
the gym
and you were to also change your
nutrition and you were to implement a
standing desk where you were not
standing while you're working
well now it's a whole
the game has changed now you get out of
the gym
and instead of you sitting down you're
more likely to do something else like
you may want to clean the house so you
may want to go for a walk or do
something like with your friends or with
your family or something like this why
because
there are more changes at play there's
more going on where your body is like
okay
we can no longer stay in the same cycle
we have to develop this new cycle
and that's
that's the whole point i'm trying to
make here yeah yeah i want to pick you
back that point because that's something
i wanted to talk about actually you'll
find a lot of commonalities i talked
about this and when i mentioned like
atomic habits and all that you'll find a
lot of commonalities you'll find that
more often than not you do the action
the same time in the same place under
the same circumstances
if i eat something unhealthy every time
i walk in the kitchen
and then i stop walking the kitchen i'll
stop eating on healthy inks right
unhealthy things that's a very
basic example right it's not going to be
as simple but you're
fine about to say it's like the uh the
snack drawer bro if you stop opening up
the snack drawer you'll stop getting
lost in the wonderland yeah exactly
exactly no don't press nothing i'm not
don't worry bro i saw you look down
don't worry bro
time so
how dare you this guy
so
uh you'll find more often than not
you're in the same place at the same
time under the same conditions right
same circumstances if you
are alone in your room at 7 p.m and you
find you're doing this a lot then don't
be alone in your room at 7 pm right make
sure you're actually with people in the
gym at 7 00 pm consistently
then maybe by the time you work out
you've had a long day you'll get back
you're too tired to want to do it or
maybe you want to do it but you're tired
enough to fall asleep so that you don't
right do this enough times
and eventually you'll have a proper
consistent cycle now it's not easy
it's not easy to be in that state where
you're like you know i want to do this
everything in my body is telling me to
do this i've done it every day for the
past like 20 years i want to do it and
then you don't that's a very difficult
thing and i don't want to undermine how
difficult that is but that's when having
a healthy environment healthy friends
proper outlets um and and just a proper
structured life is going to come in
handy i do want to say another thing
that's underrated is having more
tawakkalan and allah
of course right we should trust that
allah will help us get over and overcome
these issues
but taqwa is something extremely
underrated bro this level of keeping
allah always on your mind 24 7 as much
as we can
it prevents us from doing a lot of stuff
bro and i know i know a lot of you might
be like oh why are you talking about
that you know it's going gonna put me
off of it now that's the point that's
the point because how many people can
think of allah or think of islam and and
everything they've been blessed with and
then simultaneously go you know most
people won't most people have fitra at
the end of day so being in a state of
wudhu as much as you can really does
help because of the wadu as a shield
right and it brings purity um another
thing you can do
is get on dean moore obviously these are
basic things but i know a lot of
brothers right that have told me
directly from firsthand experience that
going to umrah or going to hajj
really did change their life masha'allah
of course as it should right that's why
it's prescribed
and allah allows those things that are
obligatory the most right but really
seeing the kaaba
going to the house of allah
game changer like they they came back
and they're like i don't smoke weed
anymore they came back they're like i
don't j off anymore they came back and
there's so many things that are just
gone from their life just like that yeah
subhanallah
yeah that's very important um there's a
hadith very famous hadith the prophet
was with his companions and a strange
man came in this man was actually
in the form of a man asked what is uh
iman what is islam it was
and this thing prophesied he described
it as worshiping allah as if you can see
him and knowing that he could see you
and that following along what you said
about having taqwa god consciousness as
if you can't see him
no worse
although you can't
yeah like you know imagine if you could
see allah right you know may allah you
know forgive us protect us i'm not
trying to say anything like outrage is
here um people in general will see allah
but in this life we're not meant to
obviously imagine if you could though
that level of worship that you would
have for allah and like every moment
that's where sen is as if you can
although you can and know that he can
see you and that comes in you know
obviously comes in handy in moments like
that where you think i'm alone no one
can see me you're not trying to think of
that actually there was a study recently
that you reminded me of fayette
um where basically it talks about
cheaters and you know when they cheat on
their spouse
a lot of them
obviously they don't think about their
spouse when they're in the moment they
try their absolute hardest to forget
everything about their life their their
their their wife their husband their
kids um you know father and
mother-in-law even work and they try and
put everything behind them as if they're
living some kind of double life so if
you were to remember allah in this
moment then you can't have two there's
going to be a battle either you're going
to forget allah or you're going to
forget what you want to do or an abstain
from it and that is is again it's
uncomfortable bro it's weird it feels
wrong it's uncomfortable but it's
something that has to be done otherwise
you're just going to fall short it's
kind of like when we talk about music
and you were like music and quran can't
exist in the same heart yeah so you you
it's really hard to like take something
out of your life except that you replace
it with something else just like anh was
saying it kind of links to what you were
saying too that you don't change one
thing except you change other things to
kind of accommodate for that you know
what i mean yeah and it's facts bro
oh and
it was crazy i saw this thing where
when
men do something like this or when
anyone does something that's uh
it's filthy it's like it's impermissible
we shouldn't be doing it yeah
within that moment
like you you're basically in a state of
disbelief because you're doing something
that's like going completely against
which you've been
told yeah you're not pulling the kaffir
card yeah i'm not thinking it's not a
state of coffer i'm not saying that but
it's like this is what i heard was like
you're doing this thing and you're
basically in a state of disbelief while
you're doing it imagine something
happens to you in that state imagine
you're gonna die in that state bro
like that that would be a tragedy
that would be a big tragedy and like
when we're talking about this like both
of you are correct you should have taqwa
and then you're correct as well where
it's like you know when when you're
getting into that state like you you're
about to fall into it you you have the
dark one it's like you have to choose
between
okay
you know believing in allah and like
fully pretending yourself to this or
just forgetting about that and then
going to this
and then it's bro like
any guy who's going through this issue
they know that like when when the naps
take over
there is no taco yeah bro it's like yeah
it's like they don't care about anything
it's like it's like in finding nemo i've
said i said this in like my very first
video on youtube
um but it's like i called it the finding
nemo effect where you remember uh the
shark
how the shark was like all all cool and
everything wanted to like be friends
like fish your friends not food yeah but
then it's like when uh the blue fish
dory had like smacked herself she had a
little bit of blood that like came out
and then the shark smelled
and his eyes just went black and then
from there he just turned to like
predator attack mode
i was like well that's what happens to
us like when our knives take over we
basically it's like we're no longer in
control like we're no longer here like
we take the back seat something else is
driving and um i don't think this is the
time and place
for me to like say in detail what joe or
ro jogen had said
ro jogen
yeah well roy jogen has said when he's
it's like when you're
when you're doing the deed it's it's
like you're driving a bus
have you have you guys heard that no uh
bro
i i'm not gonna say it because it's
it's just
this is haram
haram making light of a situation that
shouldn't be made lighter you know
that's a series
so
again
this is
the second part is figuring out what
your
day-to-day routine is like
understanding that you can't just change
one thing keep everything the same like
romney said if if at 7 pm you are in
your bed and you are
about to
you know do something you shouldn't
quit being in your bed at 7 p.m like do
something else go be with your family go
be with your friends go go outside for a
walk or something
like these are things that you have to
change you have to change your cycle you
have to change your patterns of behavior
if you want these changes to stick why
is this
because there's two things that can
happen you either put all your attention
in trying to get past the old
or you put all your attention in trying
to build the new yeah yeah and i want to
actually jump on that point there
because a lot of people are going to be
like okay i'll just get married right
and although that works for some people
believe it or not it's not actually a
solution because what happens to a lot
of people unfortunately is you they end
up carrying that issue
of uh whatever whatever
yeah that addiction into their marriage
now they're watching things other women
on their phone while they're married
that actually happens and you know this
maybe this is too soon to talk about it
maybe we'll save it for another episode
but it's all fake and they're setting
themselves up for fairly when they
condition themselves to see these women
that they see in these videos even on
tick tock and tv and other places women
don't look like that they don't and the
things they'll do to their bodies one
person was telling me about it they will
literally bleach downstairs to make it
look
more appealing or attractive they'll do
disgusting things it's all fake it's not
gonna happen
these are like there's like 15 people in
the room bro yeah while they're getting
a man
and all that stuff audio video crew
lighting yeah you know it's literally
saying uh cut action yeah yeah literally
like like i always i don't wanna call
you off but i do wanna make a quick
point here there's this guy i was
watching on youtube and he made this
analogy he was like would you ever be in
a room where two people are having
intimacy and would you just sit in the
corner and like get off to them
no
it sounds weird but it's the same thing
though with the screen of pixels yeah
what everyone's doing you know yeah 100
100 i had made the analogy a long time
ago where it's like
if you're hungry
do you watch other people eat or do you
go and eat
mmm yeah speaking of mrs b of course
yeah yeah 100
and um just to add on to the whole kind
of idea that it's fake it's like you
know you ever see the video like on like
some videos on youtube or on tv or on
tick tock it's like uh these actions
performed by professionals do not
attempt at home
unfortunately they are professionals
they have no
sensitivity down there after a certain
while they will literally do anything
they don't feel it anymore your wife is
not going to perform like that i'm
talking to men because mainly men
struggle with this right your wife's not
going to perform like that if you think
if you think she is you're in the wrong
place and you're going to ruin her life
because she's going to be depressed and
upset that she can't please you and
she's going to think she's broken it's
her fault and you're broken it's your
fault something you need to fix so
marriage is actually not the solution to
that problem unfortunately a lot of
parents will encourage that line of
thinking if you're a parent that's not
the line of things you should have you
should have the line of thinking of one
i messed up i should have taught my son
about this before i even hit puberty my
fault i take the l i move on second
point okay now let me deal with it if
they won't listen to you get someone
they will listen to to talk to them
about it they need to resolve this on
their own using the things that we
talked about send them this video
inshallah and i'll let you guys take it
from there i wanna i wanna say one more
point two before we kind of wrap up this
chapter but
a lot of the things that we will talk
about
now onward in the podcast is going to be
you know at least for this episode is
what you notice when you're doing it and
why you should actually want to change
in the first place because a lot of
people are like bro why should i work
out why should i worry about mental
health so we talked about that right but
why should people get over this
addiction why should this be something
that they stop what is the benefit of
nofap right but before we talk about the
benefits how does it mess up your life
there's one thing i want to talk about
which is this whole [ __ ] fetish right
you're basically
desensitizing yourself to watching a guy
on a screen
basically have intimacy with a woman
that you wish you were in place of like
you wish you could swap places with that
guy you wish you could be with that
woman in that in that moment
stuck for allah but instead of doing it
right in a permissible way
you now are basically
it's like his success is your success
his game is your game
and you kind of get off to the fact that
okay i can't do it but i'll be okay with
that and and that's the root of where
this whole [ __ ] fetish comes from bro
people today are are literally paying
thousands of dollars to escorts to come
and take their wife in front of them
just because that's that's the only
thing that could get them off bro
but aside from that what other dangers
or or reasons do you guys have that
people should quit this in the first
place well one thing that i heard is
desensitization yes not just
desensitization downstairs if i even say
the word correctly not just that because
i heard that you know literally touching
yourself like that in that
you know vigorous and honestly
um disrespectful manner you know rubbing
yourself like that you desensitize
you're actually damaging your
your nerves down there so you stop
feeling more and more over time you feel
less and less over time and it's very
harmful damaging and it makes actually
doing the deed harder and harder it's
not just that it actually gets you so
fixated on the the the rise that you get
out of it that
that dopamine you get out of it you
become desensitized more and more to
that as well
to the point where maybe even actually
having intercourse and being with a
woman is just
not that great to you you know if
take a man who's never ever stimulated
himself in his life and he's with a
woman for the first time that's gonna be
the second third fourth fifth time of
his life is gonna be the time of his
life you take someone who's been doing
it every day for the past like 10 years
it's not going to be as enjoyable for
the guy he's going to be
messed up and like to add on to that
it also desensitizes you in terms of
like
not physical stimulation
but the mental
stimulation the the
what's happening here like in your mind
in your brain yeah and it's like you
know when we are engaging in intimacy we
have
certain neurotransmitters that are being
released you don't have to get into
crazy detail but you have one like
dopamine
serotonin these are very very important
especially when you are
engaged in intimacy now when a man is
watching
a
i don't know well what's the word what
are we going to use the word for so we
don't get caught in video rhythm
when uh uh
when when a man is watching
and he's watching
right
what ends up happening is you're getting
this unnatural release of dopamine into
your system
you're not going to get that when you
naturally engage with your screen never
right now what's happening here is like
not only are you getting this unnatural
amount of dopamine
but
you're setting yourself up for like
certain things like you're expecting
certain things and
and
it's been known that it's called the uh
the coolidge effect
something like that
you're you're going to progressively get
into more hardcore things mm-hmm as you
watch slippery slope bro so yeah it's a
slippery slope if you get to this point
like listen there's a lot of dudes out
there that
have become gay because of this stuff
because they start watching it and they
start getting into such nasty stuff that
they actually start watching guys with
guys and we're animals bro for
bro like they kids they get and look
it's you might think to yourself oh i
stuck for a lot i would never do this no
bro like you're not safe like no one is
safe from this so you have this guy
he starts watching this stuff he gets to
the point where he's watching other
dudes and now he's confused he doesn't
even know like well am i straight am i
gay like what's going on here and then
it's like let's say he actually does
have a wife but he's dealing with this
like that's gonna add even more so to
him experiencing issues in the intimacy
so the dangers like bro you ask what are
the dangers about the dangers
is too much to list man yeah yeah it's
too much to list yeah yeah and i just to
stress the point about um
what you just mentioned you called the
coolidge effect but getting more
hardcore over time just to stress how
effective or
how dominant the topic the factor of
psychology is when it comes to intimacy
sexuality what you find attractive and
that stuff
there are and we talked about this i
think like episode three or something
there are only three ways you can
actually have a characteristic right
physical characteristics even other
types of characteristics there's either
biology or more specifically genetics
right but
overall biology right so those two
genetics and overall biology and then
there's psychology the psychological or
character characteristics that you have
you know things that you develop to like
or dislike or so on and so forth right
you might absolutely despise something
because you were raised you were brought
up and taught to despise it as a
psychological thing you could in another
world actually adore and love that thing
because you were taught to love it so on
and so forth it's like people being
taught to love islam to love the prophet
peace be upon him and others being
taught the non-muslims being taught to
hate islam hate the prophet you know
and
same thing if you look at like fetishes
for example
a lot of them if not most of them a lot
of them are the result of childhood
trauma unresolved childhood trauma and
that doesn't come out but it stays
within and when it stays within it
results in that kind of sexual manner
unfortunately now psychology is
something that obviously it's not like
you know you hit four and this is your
psychology the rest of your life you
could be 30 and have changes in your
psychology that's why people develop you
know
psychological disorders and so on and so
forth because depending on how you live
your life your environment what you
perceive what you observe your mind your
psychology the way you think whether
it's major or minor is going to change
over time so people who think that you
know and we live in a sexually
promiscuous society unfortunately so
people don't
you know understand this for what it is
but if you underestimate it it will
catch up to you
hmm
do you have anything to add to that bro
before we go on to the benefits
aside from just draining yourself bro
having no energy
messing up your testosterone bro
like i don't know why anyone would
justify a bro today there's no reason
bro
arami you know how in the quran allah
says
something like is the reward for good
anything but can you what is that that
ayah oh yeah is there a reward for a
good uh aside from good or something
aside from good yeah
is there is there a reason i'm not
trying to compare this but it's like is
there a reason to abstain from bad aside
from bad itself like the fact that
you're doing this and it's damaged like
do you need another reason like it's
literally destroying your soul bro
people have gone on the dark web and
like 85 to 90 of it is just cp
that's that's that's disgusting bro i
thought it was like people want to buy
things that they can't buy in the normal
market and stuff like that that's all it
is bro and it's it's it's crazy and it's
like the rope like in the west we
literally have islands bro
no we ain't saying that over here but
bro in the west we literally we won't
allow polygeny where a man takes care of
his women folk and has accountability
over them
but you like just for this false sense
of like let's put on this image that
there's this one woman man
and these men are cheating anyway
they're going to islands and having
these things like epstein like
bro like islam is so clean and pure
but society just wants fascia and and
filth and then haram and
this whole backwardness bro
bro and
i think like the biggest
thing that i'm gonna lay on the table
here
pause
and um
so i'm sure y'all
or anyone who has gone through this will
understand
any time
that you do something that's haram so it
doesn't just have to part you know mean
this but anytime you do something that's
haram you go against allah
you don't get rewarded
you get punished
like
you know if we die in that state of
punishment like imagine the the
punishment that's going to be in that
you have to like i wouldn't want that i
wouldn't want that for anyone either
but it's like i'm saying right now like
any time like in my life when things
have been going really good and i've
done something that i've gone completely
against allah even when i wasn't a
muslim even when i didn't have this
understanding the moment that i would do
that it's like for the next weeks to
months i would just be punished
until like i
learned my lesson
so to speak until like i came to my
senses and like really realized like
the wrong that i did
and was able to grow from that
experience
you know and i think that's something
that
we have to keep in mind where it's like
like come on man like
it's we're all about progress here
that sounds kind of weird cause like you
know
you got people saying oh islam is not
progressive i'm not talking about that
i'm saying like we all want to make
progress right like if let's say you're
playing a video game
you want to get better in the video game
you're progressing you're
getting your stats up getting the armor
weapons all this stuff right in real
life like
what we are doing
when you're getting closer to allah like
you you it's it's like a status bar like
you have to progress to get closer to
allah like you're building a business
you have to progress to the point where
like this business is fully set up
you're building your body you have to
progress to the point where your body is
fully developed yeah right like there's
there's this time and every time that
you go against allah every time you do
something every time you you do this
you're essentially just
going backwards going backwards and and
each time that you try to go forward
again like you're starting at a place
that's
further back than where you were before
so it's like why would you do that
knowing that clearly you can make it to
that angle you can make it to the point
where you
have that close connection with allah
like you have the barakah and
i don't know this is just you know like
i'm just throwing my thoughts out here
but it's something that
people in this situation dudes in this
situation really need to
keep in mind if
if this is really that important to them
i want to go into the superpowers bro
the quote unquote superpowers that you
get once you quit
benefits okay so even if it's
does it is it true that it makes hair
grow on your palms or it causes you to
get blind
no
uh okay so
in terms of the superpowers
people will experience benefits in
regards to like how bad off they were
like for instance if we have an example
of uh the benefits that people
experience
when they get onto this it's all
dependent on how
you know
bad off they were so let's say you have
this guy
who
is releasing
like five six times a day
which is not that much
all right there's a lot of guys that go
even more than this that's crazy um yeah
it is
stuck for a lot it's crazy
you have
dude who's doing like five six times
she's laughing about it i'm loving the
new sound that romney got yeah i wish we
had
all right but you had this guy he's
doing it like five six times a day
okay
this guy will experience more benefits
than the guy who's maybe doing it like
one time every three four days yeah
because the guy's doing one time every
three four days like he never developed
that bad of an issue now
um
when you start getting deeper and deeper
into it
because you're having such
unnatural amounts of dopamine being
released into your
your brain your mind it's it's causing
you to be in a state that's very
unnatural
and um
nothing in this world replicates
that
amount of dopamine like
you can't i can't sit here and talk to
you have a normal conversation and have
the same amount of dopamine yeah from
this conversation as i would if i was
over here
watching adult films yeah doing it five
six times a day
i can't yeah i can't so this person when
they stop
it's like the
brain begins to literally heal
and now it's like they're sensitizing
themselves to all these things and
because they're sensitizing themselves
they start to experience these benefits
benefits could be like increased
eye contact they're able to increase
their eye contact they're able to have
more focus
they um they feel more confident
right like why they feel more confident
because they're less stuck in their head
you know like
they're in a conversation and they feel
like they can connect with the other
person why can they connect with the
other person because they're actually
there they're present the amount of
dopamine they're getting from that
interaction is enough for them to
[Music]
function to actually be there and be
connected with them they can go outside
they can see the birds flying around and
they will have an impact on them versus
before they might have seen the birds
and it's like
eh
like it is what it is right
so that's and that's that's the benefits
now as far as like what benefits you're
going to experience that's
that's different for everyone
[Music]
so you don't get x-ray vision like i
just want to know
uh only if you go at least like three
four years
masha'allah three four years um if you
guys
did make it this far let us know what
you guys think um not that the episode's
over anything like that but
quick word from our sponsor rami
are we doing that now yeah throw it in i
was actually thinking maybe we should
why not
i don't have anything prepared um that's
true okay guys insha allah see you guys
next week same thing i'm just playing um
one question i had for both of you all
right
we don't want to air our sins or stuff
in the past or anything like that
obviously as muslims we should have
hayah and in our past otherwise put a
blanket over right
but
to the brothers and sisters that think
it's so normal bro
everyone's doing it
you know that brother ana was talking
about on the podcast that does the six
or six does it eight nine ten times a
day i'm only doing it once a day or i'm
only doing it once a week is it really
that bad that i'm not as bad as everyone
else oh everyone else is going to the
club and drinking and all this i just
drink with my co-workers once a year on
the annual whatever gala you know oh
everyone else is smoking like with
everyone recreationally i only do it
when i when i'm just you know i'm done
my work you know i study and i get my
work done you know all these people that
try to like rationalize it and they say
this whole i'm not that far gone what's
what's what's the harm in a little bit
well this is this reminds me of this
video i saw from newman ali khan
i think y'all y'all might know which one
i'm talking about nope
how do we lose our iman i think it's
that one where he's saying like um this
comparison thing it's it's of the dunya
and it's actually a sickness but he's
like what are you gonna do like let's
say
you were praying x amount of times but
you were doing all these things bad
right and then you raised up on the day
of judgment and allah is like oh you did
this and you do that he's like oh
but like
compared to this this brother over here
like he was barely praying like you sh
you should just give me the like a
straight ticket to jenna like i should
be vip janna right away because i did
much better than this guy over here
it's like well it's the same thing
it's a sickness you know you can't look
at someone else and be like oh well
i'm not doing it uh to the same extent
as them so
i'm better off like i'm not gonna have a
what i'm laughing about something from
yesterday bro yeah you remember when
rami went to bed and we were watching
the the podcast
[Laughter]
yo i just want to give a quick shout out
to our editor guys mashallah like link's
in the description for his instagram or
socials or whatever but like huge shout
out to our editor for just always being
on point with the edits color grading
everything's done alhamdulillah it's a
good word bro
but that being said i think we are going
to wrap up this episode since we are
getting a little brain dead stay tuned
for next week insha allah we're going to
go into a little bit deeper of the
topics and go into the actual intimacy
stuff
um aside from that do y'all have
anything to say yeah i wanted to answer
the question do you want to finish off
what are you saying first
um i wanted to leave him with like the
final part of the game
so uh you uh what was your question
again i had something so like all of
these people trying to like i remember
right now play devil's advocate like
yeah oh yeah i'm not as bad as everyone
else yeah yeah so i want to take it from
two different angles right
no no you're the only one that ah
this is haram
the dirtiest mind bro it's always the
quiet ones well he's finally come out
all right so i want to
approach this discussion from two
different
viewpoints respectively
in sha allah if i may
so the first viewpoint
i would like to
discuss is first i want to question
their line of thinking their logic right
so everyone's doing it and everyone
thinks it's cool and you think it's
wrong
yeah what
what were people in america doing during
the cross-atlantic slave trade what were
they propagating what were they
encouraging what did they think was
normal back then would we have the same
views today you know a few decades ago
even in
world war ii in germany what were people
propagating there would you then say
that you know since it was a majority it
was okay it was morally acceptable or
blah blah you wouldn't same thing here
look at people who are smoking people
who are drinking people who are on drugs
and so on so there's so many people
doing it does that mean it's a good
thing it's beneficial it's going to help
you or does it mean that it's not going
to harm you no not at all
actually many things even medical
practitioners will actually recommend
things that are harmful to uh to a
person remember we were talking about in
the episode about transgenderism in the
documentary what is a woman and all that
stuff they uncovered a lot of stuff
there's a lot of dark things that people
will push now that normalize that they
say it's okay but it's not so that's one
the uh the logic of it two i wanna
discuss um
these people
and look at other people doing it and so
on and so forth
why
not only why is it majority rule but the
second point i want to make on it is
just because someone's doing it worse
doesn't somehow uh excuse you from it it
might make you better in contrast to
them right but it's still fallacious in
the sense that it doesn't actually
remove the original deed the original
sin from you all right if if i come and
i'm like
you know i have the let's say angel
tells me not to eat the last um you know
i don't know a piece of chicken or
whatever and i go and i eat it anyways
and he comes and he's like why did you
eat it you know i asked you not to and i
say it's not like i ate the whole thing
yeah i didn't eat the whole thing but
that doesn't actually excuse me from the
fact that he asked me not to eat it and
then i ate it anyways the same thing
here it's you know imagine asking the
day of judgement allah asks you why do
you do this and you say well at least at
least i didn't do this well is that is
that going to excuse you i imagine
you're in court you know you you you
murdered a person and they're like why
did you do it and you're like well at
least i didn't murder the whole family
you know that's not like no you should
just let me go yanny it's fallacious i
know that's an extreme example but it
still applies there you know just doing
it once a day once a month once a year
is still worse yes it's worse than not
doing it at all and if anything you
should be comparing yourself to someone
who doesn't do it at all i want to say
one point before on wraps it up but
this whole notion of just once not
listen if you're on a streak right now
and you're thinking of relapsing because
you just want to you know just do it get
it off once so you think just what's
what's one
time gonna what is it gonna do listen
you do it once you're done yeah it's
over as soon as you do it that first
time you're already gonna be in it too
deep as soon as you do it the first time
you're gonna get back into the cycle of
like doing a couple times a week or a
month or whatever you do just don't even
do it that one time don't fall for the
trip uh tricks of shaytan don't even
give it that that footstep bro yeah
remember we were talking about in the
car right that's exactly what i was
saying
it was you right me and you in the car i
don't know ends up ends up being
something else no no i'm pretty sure i
was i don't know if you were there or
not but i was saying you know a lot of
people they they have this idea of oh i
know i just want to party one see what i
said i just want to drink once i just
want to smoke i just want to see what
it's like you're better off not knowing
what it's like
because your curiosity of what it's like
is not
stronger or worse than wanting to do it
a second time after feeling whatever you
feel afterwards people do it because it
feels good imagine you do it you know
what it feels like why wouldn't you want
it even more that second time you're
better now having not done it a day in
your life or having not done it for a
month or two months or a year or 10
years or whatever
then try and get once just to get it out
there how do you understand how do you
how do you think the the psychology of
addiction even happens people have this
amazing high the first time and they
want to recreate that first high so they
do second time third time fourth time
before they're in it ten years doing
other things other substances just to
recreate that first high when in reality
they'll never be able to recreate that
bro yeah yeah that's very true it'll
never happen
you want to end it off bro that point
well before i end it off i want to say
like
you
also these people they can't think to
themselves like oh
allah is the most forgiving
and the most merciful so i just have to
repent
that's like
dude that's like oh i'm about to i was
about to say about to finish someone off
but i'm about to end someone's life oh
but allah is the most merciful i'm going
to repent
i'm going to eat this pork but i'm going
to ask for repentance i have to like or
just say bismuth before you eat it stuff
for a lot like oh i'm gonna drink this
alcohol but i'm gonna ask for you know
forgiveness
it's basically like what we said in that
one episode where
you have a
this like a bad action with a good
intention or good in good action with
the
attention right now you have this this
bad action and then you have the
intention of like basically asking for
forgiveness
i'm sorry but like
i'm not i'm not allah but if i had to
judge like
i wouldn't accept someone's forgiveness
they're clearly going into it knowing
like
yeah one of the um well not to cut you
off but one of the conditions of tawba
is that you are sincere yeah there's
nothing sincere imagine imagine someone
coming to you right let's not make it
about us and allah imagine someone comes
to you they're like listen i'm going to
punch you but i'm going to ask for
forgiveness afterwards right
there's no class there bro not only are
they you know punching you
but if anything they they don't mean the
apology exactly it's premeditated but if
they just like if y'all were playing
around and then they actually like just
jabbed you in the face and they're like
yo like i'm so sorry bro like are you
all right are you all right yeah bro
that's sincerity yeah and on top of that
afterwards we're like i'm we're not
starting we're not going to spar anymore
i'm sorry bro yeah we're not going to do
it anymore it's sincerity yeah 100
sincerity 100 but
turn it all off
look into their souls bro to end it all
off
you now know
why you are doing what you are doing
you now know that you have to change
your day-to-day routine
your cycle your patterns of behavior you
now know the downfalls
and you know the rewards the benefits
the pros and the cons you know this
so now to bring it all together you have
to make this priority now to where
you're putting all your attention on it
because it should there should be
something in the background while you
are implementing your new life but it
should be the main priority for you to
get past this like if you want to get
married you should not even be thinking
about getting married until this is no
longer a factor in your life
if you are with
a significant other
and you guys are having issues
listen until you get over this you
should not be thinking about anything
else yeah you should not i just told him
not to think about this but you should
not be doing anything else
but like it has to take priority in your
life
you can't see it as like oh um you know
like i'll get over it eventually
that's it's not gonna work like that it
listen you have to go
all in with this
you have to do whatever it is
that you have to do everyone's going to
be different here you know some people
some people for them it takes them
saying
an oath out loud to allah like putting
everything on the table
well i know this guy
who he
actually said something like this
and
he ended up doing the thing that he said
he wasn't going to do that he promised
to allah it was crazy allah it was crazy
and
what ended up happening is that when he
did it he thought to himself oh no it's
not going to happen so he asked for
forgiveness but in his mind he thought
it wasn't going to happen
what he put on the table what he he
basically said to a lot like oh love
like if i go back like just strip this
away just take this away from me
yeah allah took everything away from me
everything that he put on the table he
he thought it wasn't gonna happen he
thought it was a joke he thought like oh
that it's i just you know like it's not
gonna happen right
not allah took everything away from him
and i mean like
you gotta you gotta put into what's with
heaven and that's where the priority
comes into play here you do whatever you
can to get past this this isn't
something to be taken lightheartedly
this is a serious thing
and
just know that your life will be better
once you do get past it
in every way shape or form inshallah
and with that being said
[Music]
my
[Music]
um
[Music]